so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
it's beautiful you finished
take your seat please
i remember the scene quite well because
uh
first off it was in a space which was
quite awe-inspiring out of all the
spaces in which we were actually uh
filming i remember when i discovered it
for the first time i was quite
uh taken aback by the lights it was one
of those scenes where we tried it the
first time in the script
it was just that sam enters the space
and then he heads to his exhibition
throne so to speak we were filming the
scene you coming
to your throne where you'll be exhibited
as it's written in the screenplay and i
was noticing that it's
uh doesn't uh say anything you know
about you
about your character and i thought that
at this moment
i had to uh trust you to give you
you know the possibility to do whatever
you want
and you started jumping and playing with
the lights and i found it
uh very uh wonderful you know and i
wasn't sure if it's
too much or not as always when we are
on a set you know but i thought it's
better and since
we already secured the sample shot with
you
you know crossing this place and i told
myself let's have
another variation and uh in the editing
i i found out that
it was really better and uh you did
what you wanted this is what i remember
from the shooting
yeah and and i think it was actually
slightly intimidating that you gave me
that freedom
and it's a big space i think we did a
couple takes
and i think it was the first take you
liked it and you're like okay do that
again
so i'm like what did i do and then you
were asking me not to hurt myself
because it was a concrete floor and it
was quite strong anyway i'm glad it
worked out nicely and thanks again for
the freedom you gave me in that scene i
thought it was um
i mean ultimately watching it again
obviously with the lighting and then
with uh amin's music over the on top of
it
it's a it's truly an experience you said
that you
wanted the music to accompanying the the
walk of
sam uh towards his throne
uh but i never imagined that it's gonna
be like this
it's very contrasted uh the colors are
are wonderful
it was not a walk he it was kind of a
dance
he was dancing choreographing all his
movements
and al all the contrasts coming from
when he's on the corridor
seeing all this baroque painting and
then
coming to this installation where lights
are
coming from all the places and this blue
dark color so it was very inspiring but
i remember that when we worked on the
script
we kind of listened to some classical
music
and you say that you wanted something
energetic but still classical but when i
saw the scene i was like wow this is
it's very contrasting because we have
this
corridor with the classical baroque
painting and then
this modern installation of art so i was
like
yeah let's try also in the score to to
have those elements from
baroque music and electronic
or more modern music so the idea was
like
create this dancing music but
based on classical colors
and and modern colors and then yeah we
we had it and then
the thing is also in the journey of
of the character emotional journey it's
the first time he
experienced this he's still
at the point where he's surprised
discovering
uh what is this place and the scene
before also he's
in front of the museum seeing this huge
uh poster with his back so he's like am
i gonna be a far
he's discovering and wondering what he's
gonna be in
thinking walking toward his throne
thinking
that he's a throne no and not yet prison
so yeah the the the music is joyful we
wanted to have this
joyful dynamic pushing him toward his
choreographic walk to towards
the throne as i said in the script it
was maybe
three sentence it was a very short scene
saying that
sam uh is uh exploring the place sam is
walking through the
corridors when we started the
preparation i knew that the places will
inspire me so
i remember chris when we were in this
museum
and we visited this corridor and
the the thing with shooting in the
museum
which is very complicated uh is
that you can't touch anything you know
and
when you have a crew and when you are a
director in general you want to
conceive reconcile revisit the place
with the light
with the said design and the museum you
can do
anything of this you can't even you know
be close to any work of art than
you know i i don't know how many
centimeters there was the guard of the
museum
in this day with us you know and people
watching
us in the with the cam you know
i knew that the part where he is
exhibited
will not be in the museum because there
is a lot of action
extras and the fight what is wonderful
with this
scene that it's set in two different
countries
the beginning is in brussels and the end
is in tunisia you know so we enter in
brussels and
and this is the magic of editing you
know we were faced by this thing
how to make this continuity believable
on the set and with the lights and just
i remember
when we discovered the place in in
tunisia i mean it's set
in a small village and it was you know
abandoned
and we were thinking together how to
make it look like a prestigious
museum which was not you know the place
was
so abundant and in a very bad shape
this scene is one of my favorite scenes
because it just feels
that it's like the magic of cinema in
terms of how
like you were saying it's just like a
few sentences and then at the end it's a
whole dance
and performance that was given birth to
after
throughout the process it was crazy for
me to have
so many places to connect and to find
the continuity in them and then
i don't know i felt that that having
this space that is not the museum was
like giving us
the total freedom of creating things
that were
of dealing and creating new spaces and
and forming them and shaping them the
way we wanted to
yeah and the nicest moment was to say
yeah yeah just
start to interact with that space and
use it
in a different way than just how it was
conceived to be
when i saw this space i i was like
very happy because i knew that i'll
conceive my own museum i conceive
my own work of art so
when he goes you know from this corridor
and he goes through this uh reversed
mirror
where he sees uh his back you know this
it's in tunisia and i discovered by the
way
now since the movie uh you know screened
in some places in the world
on internet people are putting some
references you know
and they discovered that there is a
painting by rene magritte
i think the title is not to be copied
is exactly in the same composition a guy
looking to his back on a mirror yeah and
i was really surprised because we shot
in the museum where you have all the
magritte you know and they visited this
museum you know i know
i thought i know all the work of
magritte uh
and then i found out that uh recently
that this painting is not in this uh
museum it's in rotterdam in another
place
i wanted in the scene after when the
girl he loves habir
came to the museum we see uh immediately
where she is that she is close to his
place
and at the same time i wanted to reverse
her uh
bun you know so she can see herself
from behind and in my head it was not a
reference to my great work
but to hitchcock in vertigo you know you
have this uh
scene with kim lovak looking to her
painting
so i i told myself hitchcock it's a
classic
uh you know vertigo it's a classic movie
uh and
nowadays the installation would be more
uh you know
let's say with screen and stuff uh stuff
like this
yeah all this to say that i uh had a lot
of fun
to think and to create my own museum
when we visit this place with chris we
talked about to have
a light sculpture you know because i
thought that this
place is in my head i tried to
uh tell a story about this place all the
european
museum or old castles all the
administration so you have this huge you
know
aspect of architecture and then in those
space you have
basement and some hidden places
and since i love the image of a basement
you know a dark
place where you can stall the things
that you don't want to show but in the
same time we are in this space that
shows things
so you have to go through all the museum
to found
the main piece you know the most
controversial piece
because when you have a controversial
thing you put it in the basement you
know
like to me it was more i don't know
making it look like
you're entering into a gate into a
different
dimension or it has something of a
prison
but also like it like being in the
different life or dimension
it has i i when i saw the scene it i had
a
it it was for me like he it was in a
spaceship
or where some someone like from coming
from wherever
and i i i must say something because
when you had just said cauter
i was completely blown up when cather
told me that
those installation are a complete
imagination of
coming from her and and with the work uh
with
the art director and chris so i was
completely blown up because
i was like no that couldn't be because
it it's
such a real art i mean a modern
graphic artist that i was like wow what
is this
a lot of dimension to this place and you
were
mentioning in the music the mix between
baroque
classical and electro music
and this place since it's an old uh
winery and it has something very you
know
old but in the same time i wanted you
know to imagine it
as a new church kind of church also
because it's
like like this you know with this
architecture
so i thought that maybe i have to put
not across
at the end of it but something that
remind us
uh how you call it the electrical
circuit
with lights so we designed this uh with
the set designer
uh i gave her images and references with
the light to make
an electric circuit you know
as if it across you know so you have
also in the scene this uh mixing between
the classical and baroque that you have
in
uh in the music but the paintings in
that space
the roberto ferry i actually started
appreciate because
obviously sam ali doesn't care for art
in the film but when you take
some time to look at these these
paintings they were quite wild also i
mean they added something beautiful to
the space
and we catch a glimpse of it in the
beginning of the scene
when sam is coming into that space and
we see it kind of to the right that it's
actually quite nice i don't know the
name of the
piece that we see when we walk in
roberto ferry work i discover it you
know by
accident and he is this great
contemporary italian
artist that pays homage to all the
renaissance
beauty you know he paint beautiful and
uh tortured in a way bodies and when i
saw his painting
i contacted him directly i told him i'm
creating a museum and they want to
exhibit
your work in my museum and he was
he was really wonderful he gave us the
rights and
we reproduced his uh work in this part
of uh
the imagined museum but you know there
is something else
um in the beginning of the scene
when he goes through this long corridor
when we scouted this corridor i fall in
love
i love corridors like old filmmaker i
guess
the day of shooting when we arrived you
know the day before there was
a pipeline problem in the museum so they
took many of the painting in this
corridor
and if you look carefully you will
notice a
humidity machine white ugly white
machine
and the right that didn't have the right
you know to remove
you know so it was i was sad you can't
imagine how i was sad and finally we had
to decide
should i choose another part of the
museum or i stick with my first
choice so we finished it by shooting
there
in the beginning the scene when he
enters and you have this
uh guard of the museum for me i did it
you know
it's just like his first day of work
because we see him early uh
earlier in the movie when he works in
the those
little baby chick factory and his you
know
arriving shirtless without a tattoo
and changing his clothes so i thought it
can be
very good parallel you know going to
work but the kind of work is
uh is uh changing in a way
and then in the uh preparation
i thought that it's really not very
interesting that he goes
through all this museum shirtless
because you know in general i notice it
when you have this kind of
workshop and art in museum
you have this nude you know workshop how
to paint
naked body you know they have all of
them
this kind of bathrobe and
i was thinking ah it can be wonderful if
they give him a
robe you know uh and i thought maybe
uh i i told myself all you know a
backstory to this robe you know
this museum they have only a robe for
women you know so that's why it's in
silk
so they didn't you know um choose
another kind of rope so all this to
say that i wanted this blue silk robe
you know to put it uh
inside this uh this museum
what i love the most that this scene
we can think that is he serious is he
dancing you know
and then we understand that he's teasing
the the
guard you know so you have this kind of
humor coming you know we understand why
he's doing this
to say i'm cool i'm discovering the
place you know
and i i thought ultimately to be friend
with this
strict you know very uh rigid guard
that at the end he's telling him you
finish it
okay who incidentally is is
interpreted by nadeem who's the
executive producer
what is the name that you gave to that
uh
piece that you added to that scene that
has it has a name but i forgot what it
was
i call it the museum or something like
this but
the style i think counter gave
gave it like a birth a birth to a style
which is electro baroque
and i thought it's quite sexy to
name this style electro barrage but i
thought it's a style you know my
my knowledge and music are so limited so
i told myself
oh it's electro baroque i thought it's
uh it's a genre you know
i love the idea you know the mixing
between baroque and electro so it
doesn't exist i invented it
i think yeah probably probably
i think when i saw this thing that this
rope gave gave you
kind of kind of a cape of a hero it's
kind of a cape of i don't know
super avengers re-hero or something like
that so
exactly and then therein lies the
paradox you know he really
discovers quite soon thereafter that
it's not a throne but it's rather a
pedestal from which he's humiliated